we're here in the kitchen in the news
kitchen with a very special guest
the author of the essential best-selling
cookbook that sounds so good jam-packed
with 100 delicious recipes i am actually
meeting one of my heroes for the very
first time this is me
representing cookbook club and i am
holding carla lolly music's book i have
been one of her biggest fans and i'm
actually going to meet her for the very
first time right now so please welcome
my hero carla lolly
so nice to meet you
so we're gonna chow down
and go to town on a very special edition
of news
we have got the return of an ooey gooey
classic the new york times reports that
mozzarella sticks are having a moment
welcome back yeah from viral cooking
videos to high-end restaurants and every
diner in between this nostalgic cozy
snack is back and we actually have some
here it's a classic mozzarella stick and
a hot cheese puff version thank you very
much that's the one that's gone viral on
tick tock carla why is this happening if
the question is do you want molten
cheese the answer is yes and it's always
been yes i don't i don't feel like it's
come back it just never went away should
we try it
i love you very good
this is the one whoa whoa
i like it i like the spicy one yeah yeah
i wish i had a dipping sauce it's like a
ranch or a marinara or something like
that but i did miss you dear friend
welcome back to my life i agree okay
carla you have got the next headline
fantastic so i'm a new yorker and that
means one thing i eat pizza like it's a
daily essential vitamin
but how can we combine fashion function
and our favorite food well people
magazine reports that you can keep your
pizza with you at all times with this
new pizza pouch necklace what
this makes pizza even more portable you
can have a slice and save a slice for
later
so okay
i don't know for that thought i'm a
little concerned about what might happen
at the end of the pouch you know if
you're walking around for a while but i
do like that that our own body heat
could keep the pizza warm right
oh my god right next up okay don't you
hate it when you reach the bottom of
your jar right we've all done this the
bottom of our jar and you just can't get
that little bit out we know what that's
like right well bone appetite reports
there is finally a solution and it's
called a flescen leaker it's a jar
scraper it's norwegian that's designed
to get every little bit out of your jam
your peanut butter your mayonnaise
yes and it was invented in norway in the
1900s because custard was all the rage
but it came in these tall bottles with
like a little thin neck so the
fluorescent linker was developed
to be sure that no custard was wasted
this is a game changer it's i'm getting
every little
licking bit
it's quite effective well
and it's not just us the flutter liquor
is sweeping the nation and next we're
going to go coast to coast with our
affiliates all hour long and right now
we want to go to indianapolis to check
in with eric pointer from fox59 hi eric
how are you hi eric
i'm doing good how are you guys good
morning
now i notice you have something around
your neck
is the the pizza pocket a big thing
they're awesome
[Applause]
so i would recommend
you definitely want to make sure
that it's cooled down right i put mine
in there a little hot and it got a
little um
condensation don't put it in there hot
understood now eric what is your current
food craving what is eric loving right
now you know what i just bought an
instant pot and
i've just gone crazy i'm like literally
addicted most people are like scrolling
instagram before they go to bed i'm
scrolling instant pot recipes just
looking for the next one because i love
it eric thank you so much pizza cheers
pizza cheers thank you cheers for coming
by okay our last story isn't about
it's about a brand new cookbook making
all the headlines
that sounds so good by the one and only
carla lally music yes now
obviously
i gotta get serious for a
now um
all of your the books i have of yours
are all dog-eared i gotta say this
really takes you through every technique
and really empowers the home cook it's
just
so exciting okay by the way you have
more stuff for us um you brought some
treats from yes i did a try so these are
both from the dessert section this is
the mocha hazelnut um biscotti and these
are amazing for the holiday because you
can literally make them weeks in advance
and put them in a airtight jar
so
right now i'm just angry i can't even
tell you
once again we're shoving carbs down ross
is gullible you could literally um flip
some liquor and put some peanut butter
on that that would be good and what does
this could be so this is grandma
margaret's pink party cookie it is named
for my husband's maternal grandmother
she was amazing baker and it's kind of
like an inverted oreo i i'm obsessed
with these uh-huh oh my god i was not
expecting this um oh my god the crust
the dough is so soft and moist the
center is basically like an oreo filling
but she always
tinted it pink with maraschino cherry
juice it's magnificent thank you are you
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]